my fellow Americans tonight I am
speaking to you because there is a
growing humanitarian and security crisis
at our southern border every day Customs
and Border Patrol agents encounter
thousands of illegal immigrants trying
to enter our country we are out of space
to hold them and we have no way to
promptly return them back home to their
country America proudly welcomes
millions of lawful immigrants who had
rich our society and contribute to our
nation but all Americans are hurt by
uncontrolled illegal migration all right
that was the president last night in his
address on our crisis on the southern
border joining us now is homeland
security secretary Kirsten Nielsen is
with us Madam Secretary good to see you
you were in the Situation Room today not
a very long meeting not a productive
meeting give us your thoughts I you know
as I said in the snow just have to the
meeting I just am thoroughly
disappointed this is a severe
humanitarian and security crisis the
president is taking leadership he is
taking decisive action and Congress
continues to refuse to act he's made it
very clear what the crisis is what we
need to do they have no alternative they
will not they refuse to engage and it's
very very disappointing it's
disappointing on behalf of the 240,000
men and women who are trying to secure
this country but it's also disappointing
as an American you know Madam Secretary
there's some simple facts here that you
know they're saying their party line is
this is a manufactured crisis what we do
know this we do know 90% of our heroin
comes from the southern border and that
we have about 300 deaths per week we do
know that in the last two weeks we lost
police officers saying and he has a five
month old little boy we'll never know
his father we do know Pierce Cochran his
parents were on this show earlier in the
week we do know they're 22 year old son
killed by an illegal immigrant drug
trafficking human trafficking we have
drug deaths we have other deaths
violence cartels gangs
howdy what is your response when they
say it's manufactured when these are
real people real lives life and death
and they just ignore it yeah I mean it's
it's it's offensive it's disrespectful I
can't imagine being one of these victims
families and listening to an elected
member of Congress claim that their pain
and their suffering is manufactured its
offensive is what it is but it's also
unprofessional for some people in the
media it's been like a numbers game we
do know Americans die we do know I'd
argue probably 98% of people that want
to come here want hope opportunity
liberty freedom and all the things we
may even take for granted ourselves but
it's the 2% I worry about that are part
of the the gangs the drug cartels the 2%
maybe you have talked about but you
can't give numbers there are and
instances that you can confirm that you
know of terrorists that have tried to
cross our southern border and we've
apprehended them yes John and we've
talked about the thousands that
thousands of terror watchlist
individuals who travel through our
Hemisphere last year to pretend there's
not a danger on an unsecure border on an
open border is just ridiculous if allies
common sense but it's not just a
security crisis that the president and
the vice-president continue to draw the
American public's attention to it's a
humanitarian crisis we have Doctors
Without Borders saying one in three
women on this journey are raped seven
out of ten of these migrants are victims
of violence
this is a humanitarian crisis that is
caused by the pull of the loopholes in
our law by our lack of resources and by
the refusal of Democrats to act what do
you make and how do you explain that
Chuck Schumer Nancy Pelosi Joe Biden
Barack Obama Hillary Clinton just a few
years ago 2013 they were willing to
allocate 48 billion dollars for border
security as part of a gang of a plan and
then they're making the point that it's
not needed anymore or it's manufactured
but yet if you look at the one sector in
Arizona Yuma border sector it was one of
the worst in the country
and they went from five miles of border
fencing to 63 miles and they saw a bird
of 95% in apprehensions and people being
able to cross into the country illegally
doesn't that prove the point in that one
County that it works but walls work
areas work Sean walls work I mean we
can't say it enough the facts are
incontrovertible anywhere that we have
built wall illegal migration has dropped
between 90 and 95 percent they know that
those are the facts they've been to the
border themselves they claim that
they've talked to our Border Patrol
agents they claim they're in favor of
border security with the president
continues to make clear is this is not
an either this is not an or situation
this is an and we need security at our
ports of entry and we need security
between the ports of entry you know
there is politics being played here
though Madam Secretary because it was a
crisis when they could bludgeon the
president politically and say that kids
were being separated from their parents
which should happen in the two previous
administrations and this President fixed
it or when they could say after our
border agents will be in pelted with
rocks and models they could say oh they
are Border Patrol and ice with tear
gassing children so it seemed to be a
crisis when they could politicize it but
Americans are dying in big numbers
because of that small percentage of the
criminal element drugs are coming in
every day and what do you say when
people when lives are at stake and
people are playing politics it's clear
that's politics I'd you know I hate that
I I agree with you on this point John
but I do it is politics and what I think
that I would say in response is the
president the vice president continued
to take leadership they continue to try
to solve this crisis they continue to
describe it for what it is they're doing
it with compassion I think you saw a
president last night that was very
serious that was taking a leadership
role he was showing compassion and very
importantly he was making it clear that
he continues to listen to the men and
women here on the front line who protect
this country every day often at danger
to their own lives that's what the
president's doing I don't know what the
Democrats are doing because the
president has made offers the president
has explained to them what needs to be
done they have come up with no solutions
on their own but they continue to claim
as you said that this is a manufactured
crisis
nothing could be further from the truth
all right secretary Nielsen thank you so
much for being with us we appreciate it